Now, in real life if I want to keep other people
from taking my things or messing with things they shouldn't, I use
a lock to stop them. In threaded programming, we use a
similar concept to protect memory. Let's say that inside some procedure, there's
a block where I manipulate some data, in our example, the
variable a. And I need to be sure that no other thread
touches this variable while I am working on it. Whether executing
this procedure or another one. Well then, I can declare a lock
variable, which should reside in shared memory, and put
the lock on before I have it do my manipulation,
and unlock it afterwards. And I should do the
same wherever I manipulate this variable a. If some other
thread running this code simply accesses the shared resource
without using the lock, it won't be able to stop
him. But if he does try to acquire the lock
first, then this call to mutex lock will block until
the lock variable shows that has been unlocked. And
only then will this code proceed. And, of course, if
the schedule had worked things out so that this call
had been called first, then he would get the lock.
And this call to acquire the mutex lock would block
until this data manipulation was finished, and the mutex variable
had been unlocked. And this way the threads are able
to mutually exclude each other from using resources, hence these
are called mutex locks.